welcome to this video playing a
beautiful mind and didn't he beat me a
couple of games go check I think so ok a
bogo with 92 well d 65 is some decent
way to play that check so fairly solid
setting up the dark squared center
and let's prepare that with Queenie 795
yeah I'd like to provoke d5 yeah but I
have I still have a couple of good
waiting moves that I can I can play here
here doesn't play it d 45 I am a
possible plan is Bishop f5 to e form or
Bishop f5 ID for something like that
okay he's actually pushing this okay see
ya it's may be threatening b5 here also
I probably need to simplify this oh my
dear for this is still quite solid for
black so it looks a bit better for white
due to the bishops but it's not it's not
very serious I can actually take him
it's not completely your take
yeah but okay this is probably all right
okay seven hmm maybe you can do that
what I forgot is that after i had
forgotten that to see 525 this is also
slightly annoying okay let's go here at
em
it protects a five and once the trade
and I guess rugae is having this up to
anyway okay if I take the end this this
is six hanging
hmm how to defend this c5
he threatening to to take on yet enter
and on c7 I take myself is going to take
c6 at the end
it's not exactly great it takes the 8
i'm going to take with the bishop
takes takes bishop v8
hmm check yeah it's not exactly fun to
play this
takes bishop no I for Aang's ok so he's
going to take down ok but this isn't is
necessarily the end of the world
I don't even have a good square for the
king really a really annoying
let's put this here it's still possible
to put up some resistance yeah i think
it's already a bit a bit of a time issue
i had to spend some time to even stay in
the game 3g eight meat great
checkmate yeah okay ah what is this guy
doing here I mean what check yes playing
all the right moves md5 is strong check
yeah just completely busted here this
should be should be rather tough to to
crack but yeah if you're going to play
over all the best moves all the time now
then it's so it's difficult I actually
defended this this is quite well really
chat right be five after that I have no
I've no way to to play this again okay
okay I'm allowing it made now but what
can you do yeah he just played
excellently on the queenside this is
very very narrow path from wide really
wide is better i played this great but
you really found the the most precise j
ever just if you just place one or two
sub optimal moves and this is
immediately equal and nothing happens
but it didn't didn't happen he just put
had the pressure on all the time thanks
for watching